CAREERERO KNOCKS IT AWAY.
AT THE MIDDLE AND IT'S GLOVE
DOWN BY BY DRYSDALE.
HE DROPS IT DOWN AND A COUPLE O
QUICK , STEEL VERY
CLOSELY HAD A POINT-BLANK IT TA
AWAY BY BENOIT AND IT COMES BAC?
THE SKATES DALLAS EAKINS
SAID ABOUT THE TEA
IN NICE LITTLE PASSING PLAY B T.
HE BOSTON
ZONE.
PLAY BY JAKOB SILFVERBERG.
HE STRIPS IT AWAY, UP A LOT OF
TRACKED DOWN, TRIES TO GET IT
INTO T T
ANY KIND OF CONTACT BETWEEN THE
LEFT.ROSS THE
NEUTRAL ZONE.
PUTS. FORCE A TURNOVER
DOWNLOAD.
THIS IS, BUT HE CLOSED AND PUT
PRESSURE ON  BY DRYSDALE TO
KEEP THEHE
DIVISION GAME FOR ANAHEIM.
DUCKS WILL MEET THE BRUINS FANS
LINUS ULLMARK.CAN DO
ABOUT THIS.
MILANO.
THE BRUINS AGAIN RECOVER.
>> YOU SEE HOW KIM BOARDS THE B
BACK TO DRYSDALE.EN HE GETS THI
THERE IS NO DOUBT IN MY MIND HE
IS